sometimes I'm doing well now what comes
to your mind when I teach you guys how
do you think the in Java model is called
resonance in today's time well we're
going to put this to the test a little
bit out there the social experiment
let's what you'll find out what really
happened straight after this cleaner
I've got some great exciting news the
last chance movie short movie that was
made by one path network will be coming
to the UK in the month of May the movie
was based on true events and has had a
great impact in Australia and I'm sure
it's going to do the same in the UK now
I myself will be coming along with the
movie I'll be there every single night
for every screening to meet and greet
you all
so to purchase your tickets to check it
out please go to last chance dot org dot
uk' our feelings what do you think about
the hijab in today's time like where is
it going like in terms of like college
with modesty good job just keeps going
back like you see the hair perm even
what goes bucks a job it goes right I
mean like you very differently just
depending on fashion yeah when you say
it goes back what we're talking about
I'm Sonali jams like goes back laughs it
wasn't yeah your name's no your name is
what I can salami there is modesty and
he job going today what's your force on
his job a modesty that you things going
good bad I guess it's going good and bad
I feel like those are the actions people
are both not valuing each other the same
way as it was before diffuses the people
that were talking about like I know that
some people on the street and I see that
some women like I don't know where a job
for fashion reason okay so so so so
where do you think hey job and modesty
is heading common modern yeah very more
than how in what we like there's a lot
of charisma are like impression many
many jobs like where do you think
modesty and hey job is heading in
today's time is it good is it bad like
what what world is the today's time
obviously it's not going good in a lot
you see girls obviously wearing hijab
and underwear and tight jeans
like tight clothing stuff okay and
obviously that's not going well okay I
go what is your view of how the hijab is
becoming and how it's progressing in
this modern day in age where do you
think a job and modesty is heading in
today's time I think the Java modesty
it's becoming more like the hijab is
becoming more tighter thinking more it's
become more moderate in terms of like
for example I wouldn't wear skinnies two
years ago but now you've seen hijab is
showing off their body did you say you
were you would I wanna wear skin down
low fat about the others
she gave out loud whoever buys I would
away I was like Bruce but now I wear
then we retire what tidings in this
so again okay so you're talking about
this P and hijab is heading in today's
time there'll be no hijab and a Danish
sixth unit thinking it like there's been
a lot of styles and lat for example
enormous job in Italian tonight camel
type thing you never us do enough to
take off where perhaps a night I just
one could be harder for people to wear
that's right because the time change
laws and laughing were just coming to
this country look okay you mentioned
that he drove over the head yet hijab
isn't just a headscarf is you knows how
you walked how you talk
yeah it's a lot more than just a piece
of material what do you feel how do you
feel about the way that hijab and
modesty is progressing in this modern
day and age I didn't feel badly she's
older she's doing it I think you got the
question of it messed up because you
know what I'm talking about men teacher
yeah why did you jump to the woman two
jobs now I'm talking men see jobs what
was it was a good I wasn't talking about
women I'm talking about men teacher okay
I'm talking about mintage up ha then see
job that meant a job that modesty meant
Hardesty well yeah
marginal men's modesty or soft matter
we're talking about men's a job but
mintage up ah
yeah in our religion do they teach only
women to cover up so hold on a second
okay okay why is it that when I said
hijab and modesty why did you jump
straight to female thing yes because I
didn't I just said hey job modesty and
you went straight to feeling not I'm
peeking and understand estate this is a
problem right because the hijab is for
promises world like I know it said okay
so I let her talk about because she's
the one wearing it yeah I love all of us
as men we tend to forget that we also
have a responsibility of covering and
you know of behaving in a certain modest
way etc so why do why would you
surprised it was a surprise because like
Murphy talked about women in the hijab'
when I say hijab or modesty straight we
think about woman I'm just want to know
otherwise it's over in the winter joke
you're right but I also get modest in it
okay when I said Morris teenager why did
you straight jump to a sister because
your persistence is also a monatomic he
was related yeah ask me male okay good
the only thing that's a problem that
modesty knee job is only with whenever
we hear it automatically we think of
sisters why is that isn't that wrong is
in modesty doesn't almost want an order
in the Quran how a man should conduct
himself before a woman if I was to go up
to someone random and say you know what
do you think of the hijab a woman would
come into their head why do you think
that is I think that's maybe our fault
that yeah that's you know not only this
must be men but perhaps most in women
and girls it's a I think it represents
the misunderstanding that we have yeah
and our ignorance quietly when with a
modest in hijab automatically with
single females
but we like Adam and also you think of
hearing you think letting you through
that I like the man John nurture yeah
yeah you're not kind of like especially
Muslim when women are recovering and I
met generally without really focus on
the main conference here mainly just the
women in it exactly right the will
examine rhetoric that's very interesting
you know why because you're the only one
and the first one because what is the
trick question is when we can modify any
job will get a lot of stuff in you know
sisters on life is usually talked about
sisters all talking our brothers each
idea how to respect you the fact I said
Monica a job that you refer to both male
and female
that's the name is oh yeah show them but
I don't know my wife yeah beats me bad
you know do you know what the men's job
is oh I don't think yourself yet is that
there's lowering your case but do you
know what you should be covering as a
man
what was your father yeah well you cover
up as male from your neck to toe toes
from a naval even able to the meat yet
it should men wear tight clothes yep no
we should not you know why because it
shows the others I meant to job it for
example I believe covering your ankles
for example oh okay the lower gaze maybe
I don't know no in case yellow gates how
you conduct yourself we should cover
from our navel to I need no tight jeans
yes company you know as males men we
need to cover up his work we have to
cover from my navel back for example yes
from the belly button area telling it
good you know Marcia Lea we total Iraqis
good how we speak in a good manner and
it's good good good yet I know some
people that wear tight jeans and stuff
yummy yeah and some of them sometimes
when it comes to the summer the wear
shorts are but and that's not battle is
neither about any yet so obviously all
the Diana lie
not doing it right make sure the child's
laugh in it and that's what we mean even
the way they dress I detention as a sign
that the house are meant to be and
everything okay you know they have to be
covered from the navel to the knees yes
and they can't wait at home you know
like tight tight jeans and stuff that is
abandoned a lot of the people have been
asking today I have linked the hijab to
only females right so what this social
experiment is actually about is linking
the hijab to Mills right again because
Isis knows we also have responsibility
it's certainly our bearded or hijab
yeah in a certain extent and like the
way we should be dressing I very
modestly yeah yeah the way you freaking
insole so don't you think that's where
does that problem where does that come
from this mentality of modesty when you
say modest people automatically think of
a female why not I mean where does this
come from families that have females
that normally will be like yo I just
wear the jersey mother supremo's I mean
it's pretty much same fit for them now
okay yeah okay you feel like we're more
harsh with the women in reversal of
where they should dress but the men kind
of gets a slide with the way that they
can dress I don't have that with my wife
who's off camera yeah yeah I think I try
to picture the same sort of rules that
require to be able to me that was her
well thanks Daniel how like it's more
expected for the women talking women
from childhood that what he has for
women and example women has not really
taught for men exactly so we want to
change that with this object so where do
you think that comes from this whole
mentality when we say hijab and modesty
we automatic with single females why are
we programmatic in exams even coaches
and stuff it's emphasized mostly on that
the women yeah I don't really don't
think about the amendment yeah so what
that means is actually we need to
implement more of the Quran and Sunnah
because culture are fortunate teachers
of this fulfills that even when it comes
to marriage in it you want to get
married not from our cost but the
DeSantis that
do you feel like it's culture that
causes people to think that your job is
only for females yes definitely
what would you say the brothers out
there who criticize like everything they
feel bus in star hijab collar disturb
but when it comes to when they go
holiday topless when they summertime
they don't cover properly like what make
him to gather them up they take a leaf
out your own book first man you know
Quran says don't be a hypocrite don't
contradict yourself we we don't wear a
hot enough sleeve no more man so a lot
of brothers man picks up yourself then
go preach what you know yeah like one of
the song mistaken might even have fun
you know he was a companion who had so
much higher even the former Tsar saltan
would cover himself to get it you say
this is a man that angels get shy of you
know so it's just like a little like
reminder for everyone that hit modesty
is not just for females anything else
what I don't myself Antonella black you
really to say
when we asked before the reason why we
do this if I turn on a light
how many try to look bad hey give me one
I'm sorry
subscribe